je tiens à dire que ces sanctions contre
la Russie
seront immédiates
lourdes et efficace
ne laisseront pas le président Poutine
violet le droit international sans
réaction forte
c'est sanctions porteront notamment sur
le secteur financier
pour empêcher la Russie de se financer
sur les marchés européens
elle pourrait comporter la désignation
individuelle d'un certain nombre de
personnalités politiques et économiques
russes et enfin elle pourrait être
entraînée le gel des avoirs de certaines
banques publiques russes nous visons je
le redis des sanctions immédiates
lourdes et efficace pour riposter à la
décision russe de l'escalade dans le
conflit
ukrainien
[Musique]